[Music]
Lauren Burnham is getting ready to say I
do to our elion Dyke jr. wedding
planning Authority Magana the 26 year
old former bachelor winner celebrated
her bridal shower over the weekend in
her hometown of Virginia Beach both
Lauren and her leading man documented
the bash on social media which get this
was tropical themed in honor of the
couple's upcoming nuptials in Maui I'm
just excited to start a life with her
the bride-to-be shimmied with her gal
pals dined at a table fit for a luau
chow down on personalized cookies donuts
and tropical fruit rocked bridal white
as she posed by her mama and if that
weren't enough to give you all the
fields just check out this video of
Lauren's fiance dancing with her grand
mom the lovebirds got engaged on the
bachelor finale earlier this year we
Miami since then they've purchased a
house and are quickly approaching their
January wedding date ET recently caught
up with a couple and Lauren revealed
planning for the big day has been a
breeze I thought I'd be more of a
bridezilla on a cleaver I'm not
stressing much at all
and while the next step is starting a
family they said it could be a while I
don't think you can really plan for
something like that I think it kind of
happened
[Music]
[Applause]